excellencies ladies and gentlemen
our world is in big trouble the UN
Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
setting a grim tone for this meeting
among the many conflicts in the world
that continue to rage won the war in
Ukraine will dominate proceedings this
week
and as the meeting was taking place news
was confirmed that in the Ukrainian
provinces of luhansken Donetsk votes
within days will take place on whether
to become part of Russia this was the
reaction of the U.S ambassador to the UN
they will not be recognized by anyone in
the International Community they were
not recognized in 2014 and it will not
be recognized uh this time around it is
illegal annexation of another country's
territory NATO's Secretary General told
me he believes Russia may be acting now
because of the losses it suffered during
the recent Ukrainian offensive
have no legitis Museum because they are
a shame referend us and they will not
change the nature of the war this
remains a war of aggression against
Ukraine and it represents an escalation
because if suddenly these territories
which are part of Ukraine are declared
as part of Russia that will further
escalate the conflict the general
assembly heard from two leaders who've
maintained a dialogue with President
Putin throughout the war the president
of turkey recipe type erdogan helped
negotiate a deal to export the grain
from Ukraine he says there now needs to
be a dignified end to the war president
Emmanuel macro of France in an
impassioned speech was much tougher on
Russia
as I am speaking to you now there are
Russian troops in Ukraine but as far as
I know there are no Ukrainian troops in
Russia that's a fact and we all have to
recognize that the longer this war goes
on for the more it threatens peace in
Europe and the entire world it leads to
a wider permanent conflict where the
sovereignty and security of everyone
will only depend on power what we have
been witnessing since February 24th is a
return to imperialism and colonialism
Ukraine is expected to be one of the
focuses of President Biden's speech to
the general assembly on Wednesday
there's also a speech delivered by video
by President zielinski and on Thursday a
meeting of the UN Security Council at
foreign minister level again on new
crane James Bay's Al Jazeera at the
United Nations